en el vídeo pasado estudiamos el caso en
el que ya no me conocieras tú o yo
teníamos una probabilidad de anotar una
canasta de 70 por ciento que bueno la
verdad esta probabilidad es muy alta
para mi seguro la probabilidad de que yo
anoté un tiro libre es mucho más baja
pero bueno en ese escenario en el que la
probabilidad de que anotemos una canasta
en un tiro libre es de 70 por ciento
como dijimos entonces la probabilidad de
fallar un tiro libre es de 30 por ciento
y vimos que si hacemos seis intentos si
tiramos seis tiros libres la
probabilidad de anotar exactamente dos
canastas anotar dos de esos tiros libres
es esto que tenemos por aquí ok porque
hay este número de formas de anotar dos
canastas en seis tiros libres tenemos
las combinaciones de seis en dos formas
de anotar exactamente dos canastas
y cada una de esas formas tiene esta
probabilidad de aquí porque tenemos que
anotar dos canastas y eso sucede con una
probabilidad de punto siete al cuadrado
y tenemos que fallar cuatro tiros libres
y eso pasa con una probabilidad de punto
tres elevado a la 4 pero bueno aquí
sacamos la probabilidad de una situación
muy específica sin embargo podemos
utilizar este mismo razonamiento y
generalizar este resultado y es justo lo
que vamos a hacer
nos vamos a preguntar por cuál es la
probabilidad de anotar
otra vez exactamente
shak
mente y utilizando otro color utilizando
naranja vamos a poner el número de
canastas que hacemos que nos interesa
cuál es la probabilidad de notar
exactamente que tiros libres o canastas
estas
y ahora con morado el número de tiros
libres aunque el número de intentos
en todos y esta probabilidad es igual a
ver de cuántas formas podemos escoger
cada cosas entre n cosas pues eso son
las combinaciones de n
en objetos escogemos que de genet y dos
libres escogemos que son los que vamos a
anotar y bueno vamos a generalizar lo
todavía más ahora digamos que en lugar
de que tengamos una probabilidad de
anotar una canasta en un tiro libre
igual a 70 por ciento digamos que
tenemos una probabilidad de de anotar
una canasta en un tiro libre aunque
sabes que en realidad no importa qué
letra le pongamos también podría hacer
efe por ejemplo así es que vamos a decir
que la probabilidad de anotar una
canasta en un tiro libre sf en esta
situación que estamos generalizando por
completo
es la probabilidad proba de la jugada de
anotar un tiro libre de anotar anotar un
tiro libre entonces si quieres hacer eso
tienes una probabilidad de efe efe
elevado a la k pero también tienes que
fallar el resto de los tiros y si ese es
la probabilidad de anotar entonces la
probabilidad de fallar es 1 - efe y
cuantos tiros nos quedan si ya anotamos
k tiros pues tenemos n tiros en total de
los cuales ya anotamos k o sea que nos
quedan n - katy los que tenemos que
fallar y aquí te recomiendo que hagas
una pausa y pienses muy bien acerca de
lo que acabamos de hacer piensa si
realmente entiendes cómo se parece esta
probabilidad a esta otra probabilidad
que aquí teníamos una probabilidad de
anotar de puntos
y aquí tenemos una probabilidad de
anotar de f por aquí veíamos cuál era la
probabilidad de anotar dos canastas en
seis intentos y aquí estamos viendo cuál
es la probabilidad de anotar que en en
intentos y realmente esto de aquí es la
generalización de lo que hicimos por
aquí en el vídeo pasado en aclarar y
hasta lo podemos ver si f es igual a
punto 7 entonces 1 efe es punto 3 y si n
es igual a 6 y acá es igual a 2 por aquí
tenemos 2 y aquí tenemos 6 menos 2 que
es 4 si es que podríamos decir que este
es un ejemplo de esta forma más general
y bueno yo quería llegar a esta parte
porque esto que calculamos aquí está
súper interesante porque si sustituimos
la n y la f por algunos valores fijos y
dejamos la k como una variable lo que
tenemos es la función de masa de
probabilidad de una variable aleatoria
la variable que cuenta la cantidad de
canastas anotadas en n intentos
donde f es la probabilidad de anotar un
tiro libre o si n es igual a 6 y f es
igual a punto 7 entonces esto de aquí es
la función de masa de probabilidad de la
variable aleatoria que cuenta cuántas
canastas anotas en seis intentos cuando
la probabilidad de anotar es 70% pero
bueno eso lo vamos a ver con más detalle
en el próximo vídeo porque si no este
sería un vídeo muy largo